- So the headlines read that
Remington is subpoenaing
the student records of the first graders
who were shot and killed
in the Sandy Hook massacre.
So I assume that in this litigation,
Remington issued a very
broad discovery requests,
something along the lines of
all documents related to the children,
and someone blew it out
of proportion by saying,
oh, they're specifically
requesting educational records
which have no relevance.
Actually not so,
and the headlines are
actually pretty accurate here.
I took a look at the actual
discovery requests which read,
"Any and all educational
records in your possession
"including but not limited to,
"application admission paperwork,
"attendance records,
transcripts, report cards,
"disciplinary records, correspondence,
"and any and all other educational
information and records
"pertaining to each of the
five first graders at issue."
So yeah, those are
actually much more specific
than I thought,
and it's hard to see
what kind of relevance
those documents would have in
this particular litigation.
And so, as a result,
the plaintiff's lawyers are
trying to get a protective order
to prevent the disclosure of those records
related to the first grade children
who were killed in that case.
And they probably stand
a pretty good chance
of quashing that subpoena,
but we'll see what happens in court.